will help me understand what is the
impact kind of forward-looking here if
that theory holds true and so far it
seems to be that's what's happening in
this liquidity crisis and the dollar
strengthening cetera what's the impact
on equities and commodities and then
even other foreign currencies do we just
see oh that everything continued to
bleed out and the dollar strengthened
against it or something else happened
well let me let me qualify this by
saying this is not gonna happen in a
straight line this is you know nothing
happens in a straight line there's gonna
be fits and starts and there's going to
be ups and there's going to be pull
backs but in general over the next
couple years what I think will happen is
I don't know if we found the bottom and
equities yet or not III own equities I'm
long equities I think two or three years
from now equities will be much higher
than they are right now not because
things are good in the world and not
because things are good in the US but
because they're bad and we will be a
recipient of flows as a relative not an
absolute but as a relative safe haven so
I think two or three years from now due
to all the money printing and due to the
effects of that and the facts of sucking
in the money printing from around the
world will push us asset prices higher I
think it will push US stocks higher I
think it will allow us to fund our
budget deficit even though you know I
think the rest of the world is gonna
have budget deficits as well but I think
we will be able to fund our budget
deficit easier than the rest of the
world will be able to fund theirs again
it doesn't mean that it's gonna be
perfect it doesn't mean that's going to
be easy but I think that will allow us
to happen and as as that happens I think
that keeps a bit under the dollar I
think the dollar goes higher and I think
it continues to put incredible pressure
on the rest of the world because they
have this dollar debt that they have to
service and you know global commerce
takes place in dollars so you know I've
used this example before but if there's
a Peruvian gold mine that's selling gold
to China and it's financed by a bacon
Bank in Japan the invoice is back and
forth between the three are probably in
dollars you know it that's just what you
know or copper or whatever it is you
know when we get sent to China these all
take place in dollars because that's the
global reserve currency
so whether or not countries like the
dollar it doesn't really matter until
there's a viable opportunity otherwise
that can be used on a global scale you
know I think the dollar gets a bit now
it doesn't mean that things like Bitcoin
won't go up it doesn't mean that gold
won't go higher maybe there's some other
altcoins or stable coins or you know
maybe you know countries start to issue
digital coins of their own that do well
but until something can replace the
global reserve system or the global
reserve currency system and there's
another country that can enforce its use
the dollar is still going to be the
predominant currency and so right it
becomes this big vicious circle whereas
the dollar gets a bid and us a process
of asset price has come up I think we
get those flows because we come more
attractive that flow of liquidity that
means that the rest of the world is Dean
being denied liquidity so they continue
to have pressure on them but it could
also be that we start to because now
we've got supply shortages whether its
food or mines shut down and minerals and
steel and other commodities aren't as in
abundance you know but the u.s. still
needs them maybe there are some
inflationary effects and some but that's
not necessarily good for emerging
markets either because now maybe their
input costs are going up or they're you
know typically in emerging markets or
less developed economies food is more
expensive more bigger percent of their
overall budget and as food prices start
to rise their you know their cost of
living goes up but they're in a
depressed economy so their revenues so
they're getting squeezed from both sides
and as they get squeezed I think that
liquidity gets squeezed out of those
countries and it flows back to and again
it creates this vicious cycle and it
ends really badly for everybody
including the United States but I think
I think before that happens we get this
big short squeeze in the dollar and I
was talking to somebody else and I said
anybody who's ever seen a short squeeze
will never or have been involved in
short scoop will never forget it because
you just cannot believe how high the
price of that thing goes it's just
amazing and then you never forget the
other side of it because it just crashes
after
as well like short squeezes don't go
from like Tesla it went from four
hundred to a thousand an ounce back at
four hundred it doesn't go from 400 to
4,000 and stay at four thousand that
never happens you get the big you know
ramped up and then you get the crash and
I kind of think that same thing will
happen with the dollar I think we're
gonna get this big short squeeze on the
dollar over the next couple years it's
gonna go higher than anybody believes
possible it's gonna create chaos
everywhere eventually the world will
come together they will do something I
don't know if they have another Plaza
Accord or it's written down or it's
devalued or you know the world says you
know we were Gold's now at seven
thousand dollars because of all the
chaos that it's caused and you know I
don't know how they're gonna do it but
eventually this will all reverse and
then the dollar will have a big slide
the US will lose all the capital flows
the rest of the world will start to
receive the capital flows and they will
inflate while we deflate so I I kind of
see it like a teeter-totter I think I
think over the next couple years we'll
be going down while there or will be
going up while they're going down and
then it'll all flip and it'll go back
the other way that's a very simplistic
way of saying it but that's kind of how
I see it playing out got it so that
makes a lot of sense now one of the
things that it makes me immediately
think of so right now we're seeing in
this liquidity crisis is everyone is
selling any asset they possibly can into
a liquid market to get dollars right
we're seeing the dollar strengthened
you're seeing these commodities Bitcoin
everything's going down there is a
number of people who would argue and I'm
actually probably one of them that would
say in order for those asset prices to
stabilize and eventually recover you
need to have some weakening of the
dollar at some point you've got a pretty
interesting theory around the dollar
itself can strengthen and so could the
asset price of say gold or other assets
at the same time maybe uh unpack kind of
the nuance there between what is more
theoretical I think in you know
weakening the dollar asset prices
recovering versus maybe they all could
go up at the same time
yeah so there's a couple parts to this
and this is the part where I probably
get challenged on the most there's a you
know there's a lot of people who think
the dollar is gonna go lower there's you
know I think there's a lot more people
to think it's gonna go lower than higher
but you know you could argue that
there's a lot of people who think it's
gonna go higher but most of the people
that think the dollar is going to go
higher also thinks that's going to lead
to just a depression in the United
States as well
and that's where I kind of disagree and
and I think that we're gonna get into a
situation and we'll listen we're not
there yet but I think we're gonna get
into a situation where US asset prices
rise the US dollar rises perhaps even
I'm gonna people are gonna think I'm
crazy
interest rates might rise a little bit
and we will have some inflationary
effects in the United States even though
the dollar is getting higher a lot of
people equate the dollar losing value
with inflation and of course that makes
sense but if but if but if the dollar is
going higher because capital is flowing
in and the capital is leading to higher
asset prices you can get some
inflationary effects that way too maybe
it doesn't happen as often maybe that's
not the traditional way that people
think about it but but it can happen and
so if we start to if if that starts to
happen and we start to get some
inflationary effects in the United
States and this I'm not talking tomorrow
the year from now 18 months from now two
years from now right and now it's also
at the same time causing chaos overseas
or in the less developed markets or
wherever it is and people start you know
they're buying dollars as a flight to
save him but they're not gonna put all
their money in dollars in the same way
that I talked to people in the gold
world and I say well people are gonna go
to gold well of course they're gonna go
to old but they're not gonna put all
their money in gold right they're also
not going to put all their money in
dollars they might put a lot of it but
they'll put some in Bitcoin
they'll put some in gold they'll put
some in some other safe haven trades and
I think we'll get to a point where safe
haven trades rise together I don't think
that's happening right now because right
now we're just in the liquidation phase
just like you said just give me dollars
because you might want Bitcoin you might
want gold you might want your Rolex
watch
but what you need is dollars right and
so it the the point I always try to make
to people is it's it's not about what
people want it's what they need you know
in when you do go down the the the
pecking order you start with what you
need then you start with what you'd like
to have then you have your dreams and
your hopes and you know but you start
with your needs right and and thing is
you know I would love to see a world
where where gold was a bigger part of
the financial system and you know
governments were had some fiscal
handcuffs on them and we went to more of
a true store of value where you could
measure you know with a with a fixed
yardstick how you were doing as opposed
to you know this crazy Rube Goldberg
machine that we've built but as much as
I would like that that's not reality
like the reality is is we have central
banks who print money and we have
Keynesian economics now I think
eventually we'll get to a place where we
don't but right now we do and I think
right you know as people try to escape
the system they'll go to safe havens you
know alternative forms of money whether
it's digital currencies or whether it's
Bitcoin whether it's ripple whether it's
gold
whether it's diamonds whether it's you
know seashells I don't know but I think
they will go to other things but the
dollar I think until there's a viable
alternative I think the dollars gonna
get the majority of those flows so I
think we'll get into a situation where
the dollars rising Gold's rising Bitcoin
will probably be rising or some form of
you know digital currency will be rising
and then you know it's possible that
we'll get into a situation where they
all rise together and then the dollar
falls off and that's when we roll and
that's when gold really goes through the
moon or that's when Bitcoin really goes
higher but I think right now we're still
in the liquidation phase I'm not
convinced the liquidation phase is over
well I think we're getting close but I'm
not sure that we're there yet
but I think you know I'm not ready to
buy commodities yet even if we're
getting close to the bottom of the
liquidation phase in equities I'm not
sure we're to the bottom of the
liquidation phase and commodities and
that includes gold again I think
everybody should own gold I think
everybody should have some Bitcoin I'm
just not convinced they're gonna pay off
yet